Right.
So I like,
well,
you know,
I want to get into this because this is a,
I think this is a fascinating thing with you personally that your diet,
um,
you're on this carnivore diet now.
Okay.
So I want to preface that with something.
I am not a dietary expert so I'm now speaking as an uninformed citizens.
Yes.
Well this is anecdotal evidence from a human being that is dealt with autoimmune
issues their whole life.
Yes.
You have done this for how long now?
I'd been on a pure carnivore diet for about two months and a pretty,
a very,
very low carb greens only modified carnivore diet for
bout a year.
So in the year
and,
and the low carb diet for two years.
From the time that I've known you,
I've known you for what,
two and a half years now.
Something like that.
Yeah.
When I first met you,
you had much more weight on your body.
You look different.
Yeah.
And you were at back then you were eating like the standard diet,
right?
Like normal people.
Yes.
Pasta,
bread,
chicken,
whatever.
Right.
You shifted over to only meet and Greens.
I saw you and I'm like,
did you look fantastic?
I'm like,
what are you doing?
And you're like,
I changed my diet.
I only meet and Greens,
and I was like,
wow,
that's fascinating.
Well,
I felt like,
okay,
what you're doing is cutting out refined sugars and all these different things
that are problematic,
a preservatives,
all the bullshit processed foods and you're having this extreme health benefit,
and I was like,
wow,
that's really excellent.
You're showing great discipline.
Then you decided to take it to another place and cut out the Greens.
What was the motivation for cutting out the green?
Well,
all of the motivation for this has been my experience with my daughter because
she has an unbelievably serious autoimmune disease.
I just talked to her.
This wasn't called,
well,
it's arthritis,
but it,
there's,
there's way more to it than that,
but the arthritis was the major set of symptoms.
She had 40 affected joints and she had to have her hip replaced in her ankle,
replaced when she was 15 and 16.
And so she basically hobbled around on two broken legs for two years in extreme
agony.
And that was just a tiny fraction of the,
of the whole set of problems.
I just talked to her this morning.
She's in Chicago,
looks like she has to have her ankle replacement replaced.
So that's next on the horizon.
But uh,
but apart from that she is doing so well now.
It is absolutely beyond comprehension.
So she's,
she's,
she's very trim.
She had a baby,
but she's very trim.
She's down to about 118 pounds.
She's about five foot six.
She's just glowing with health.
All of her autoimmune system symptoms are gone,
all of them.
And she was also seriously depressed,
like severely depressed,
way worse than you think.
She couldn't stay awake for more than about six hours without taking Ritalin.
Um,
and she was dying and I had a cousin,
my cousin's daughter,
she died when she was 30 from an associated autoimmune conditions.
So there's a fair bit of this in our family.
It was bloody bleak.
I'll tell you.
And my wife always had a suspicion that this was dietary related.
You know,
and I,
well we did notice that when Mckayla was young,
if she ate oranges or strawberries,
that she'd get a rash.
Like there were there were there.
And then when she developed arthritis,
if she ate oranges in particular,
that would definitely cause a flare.
It was the only thing we could see.
The problem is,
is that in order to identify a dietary component,
the response has to be pretty quick after you eat the thing.
Like if it's two days later,
how the hell are you gonna figure that out.
A lot of these responses appeared to be delayed for four days and last a month.
So good luck figuring that out.
Anyways,
mckayla noticed about three years ago,
no more than that now,
five years ago,
she was at Concordia University and and struggling with her with her illness and
all the associations associated problems,
she noticed that around exam time she was starting to develop real skin
problems.
And my cousin's daughter,
who I mentioned had really bad skin problems and wounds that wouldn't heal.
And that was partly part of the process that eventually killed her and she
thought,
oh,
it must be stress.
And then she thought,
wait a second,
I really changed my diet when I'm studying.
All I do is eat bagels.
All I do is eat bread sandwiches.
She thought maybe it's the bread.
So she cut out gluten first and it had a remarkable effect,
like really remarkable effect.
And then she,
she went on a radical elimination diet all the way down to nothing but chicken
and Broccoli.
And then her symptoms started to drop off one by one like,
and,
and like one of the things that happened is she started to wake up in the
morning,
she started to be able to stay awake all day when you're only staying awake for
six hours with Rhydlin staying awake all day.
That's like having a life.
And so a whole bunch of things improved.
Their depression went away.
And I've had depression since I was 13 probably in very severe.
And I've treated it a variety of ways.
Some of them quite successfully,
but it's been a constant battle in my father had it and his father had it and
it's all just rife in my family and my wife has autoimmune problems.
And heard you say depression.
Define it.
Oh.
Oh,
uh,
how would you define it?
Because that's a war.
That's a blanket term.
Yeah.
Well imagine,
imagine that you wake up and that you remember that all your family was killed
in a horrible accident yesterday.
The,
you would feel that even if nothing's wrong.
Yes.
Just,
just a worse than that because we like,
well,
one of the things Mckayla told me what she thought,
what's it like to be depressed?
Who Imagine you have a dog and you really love the dog.
And then the dog dies.
And then about two,
three years ago,
our dog died and that was MCKAYLA's dog.
And she really liked that dog.
And she said that was bad,
but it's nowhere near as bad as being depressed.
And I asked her to,
at one point when she was about 15 or 16 I said,
look,
you've got a choice kid.
Here's the choice.
You can either have depression or arthritis,
which what I'll take the arthritis.
Well that was after she'd lost two joints,
so it was no joke.
It's no joke,
man.
It,
there isn't any,
no,
I wouldn't say that.
I wouldn't say there's nothing worse cause worse is a very deep hole,
but it's bad.
You know,
people prove you wrong,
right?
Oh yes.
Definitely works worse is a deep hole.
Anyways,
her depression went away.
All these symptoms went away and like radically.
So what changed her from chicken and Broccoli to carnivore?
Well,
she,
she kept experimenting and she got very sensitive to all sorts of foods in the
aftermath of that too.
So this is why I wouldn't recommend that anybody does this casually because we
don't understand much about it.
But the upshot was that while she kept,
she kept,
she kept experimenting and she started to add things back and take them away.
And sometimes when she added things,
the results were devastating.
She was like done for a month.
She eat the wrong thing done for a month.
All the symptoms came back.
The depression came back.
She thought that her whole dietary theory was wrong because it lasted so long,
was so extreme and flick.
It took her two years to figure out that really what she could eat was beef and
greens and then she figured out that she could only eat beef.
So Greens themselves.
Well,
look,
so what happened happened.
Okay,
so two years ago she said,
dad,
you have to try this diet because you have a lot of the same symptoms as me.
Now I didn't have arthritis,
but I had a lot of the other symptoms and I thought,
oh Christ,
okay mckayla,
I can try anything for a month.
She said,
try it for a month.
I thought,
okay,
whatever.
I can hang by my fingernails from the window sale for a month.
It's like,
it's just not that big a deal.
And so I,
I eliminated,
I went on really low carb diet.
Okay,
so this is what happened.
I had gastric reflux disorder and I was snoring quite a lot.
I stopped snoring the first week.
I thought,
what the hell that's supposed to be associated with weight loss?
Because I had gained some weight.
I weighed about 212 pounds and I'm about six one and a half.
So that was my maximum weight stopped snoring,
which was a great relief to Tammy that just quit.
And that's a big deal,
right?
Cause if you snore,
you have sleep apnea and then you don't sleep right.
It's like not a good thing.
Okay.
Next I started waking up in the mornings.
I'd never been able to wake up in the mornings my whole life.
I always had to stumble to the shower and then maybe I could wake up,
took me an hour and I felt terrible.
And so all of a sudden I woke up,
it was like,
Whoa,
look at that.
I'm awake in the morning and I'm clear headed and,
and things aren't gloomy and horrible.
It's like,
well,
he's not weird.
Then I lost seven pounds the first month.
I thought seven pounds.
That's a lot in a month.
And I'd already gone for a whole year on a sugar free diet and I didn't lose any
weight and I'd been exercising sugar free.
But did you cut out bread and no.
Nope.
It was just no desserts,
no sugar,
no.
And I thought that might do,
it didn't make any difference at all.
Seven pounds.
Well then,
then I lost seven pounds in the next month.
Then I lost seven pounds the next month I lost seven pounds every month for
seven months.
Like I'd throw away all my clothes.
I went back to the same weight that I was when I was 26 and my psoriasis
disappeared and I had floaters in my right eye and they cleared up.
And then the last thing that went away from me,
I was still having a bitch of a time with mood regulation and not suck because
when I changed my diet,
I didn't respond to antidepressants properly anymore.
They weren't working.
And so although I was getting better physically on a variety of ways,
like radical ways,
um,
I was really having a bitch of a time regulating my mood and I was having
sporadic,
really negative reactions to food when I ate something I shouldn't.
So that took about a year and a half to clear up and I was still really anxious
in the morning up to three months ago,
like horribly.
And then it would get better all day.
People said,
well,
you're under a lot of stress.
And I thought,
yeah,
I've been under a lot of stress for like 10 years.
It's like it's a lot,
but it,
it wasn't any more stressful than helping my daughter deal with her illness.
That's for sure that,
no,
this is something different.
And she said to me,
quit eating Greens and I thought,
Oh really?
Jesus mckayla meeting cucumbers,
lettuce,
Broccoli and chicken and beef.
It's like,
I have to cut out the God Damn Greens.
He's like,
try it for a month.
Okay.
Within a week I was 25% less anxious in the morning within two weeks,
75% and I've been better every single day.
I'm better now probably than I've ever been in my life and I haven't been taking
antidepressants for a whole year,
so I don't know what.
And I weigh 162 pounds like I have.
No,
I'm,
and I've actually gained musculature.
I've been doing some working out,
but not a lot.
And so I can sleep six hours a night.
No problem.
I wake up in the morning,
I'm awake.
If I take a 15 minute nap that used to take me an hour to recover from,
that's gone.
Here's the coolest thing.
I've had gum disease since I was 25 as being serious enough to have,
I've had to have minor surgical intervention scraping and that sort of thing to
keep it at bay.
It's gone.
I checked with my dentist before this last tour,
no inflammation.
And that's associated with heart disease by the way,
come inflammation and gingivitis.
It's a good risk factor for heart disease.
It means that the systemic inflammation is gone and it's not supposed to happen.
You're not supposed to recover from gingivitis.
And my gums are in perfect shape.
It's like,
what the hell?
So here's what happened.
I lost 50 pounds.
It's like,
that's a lot,
right?
I'm nowhere near as hungry as I used to be.
My appetite's probably fallen by 70%.
I don't get blood sugar dysregulation problems.
Um,
I need way less sleep.
I get up in the morning and I'm fine.
I'm not anxious.
I'm not depressed.
I don't have psoriasis.
Um,
my legs were numb on the sides.
That's gone.
Um,
I'm certainly intellectually at my best at the moment,
which is a great relief.
Especially doing this tour.
Depression is gone.
I'm stronger,
I can swim better.
Um,
and my gum disease is gone.
It's like,
what the hell?
And you've done,
you've done no blood work,
so you don't know what your lipid lipid profile is or,
no,
I'll get that down again when they go back.
Take any vitamins.
Nope.
No.
I eat beef and salt and water.
That's it.
And I never cheat ever.
Not even a little bit.
No,
not soda.
No wine.
I drink club soda.
Well,
that's done.
It's still water.
Well,
you know,
when you're down to that level though,
it's not Joe.
There's,
there's this club soda,
which is really bubbly.
There's Perrier,
which is sort of bubbly.
There's flatwater and there's hot water.
So
those distinctions start to becoming blind.
It's crazy.
Well,
we ate last night and I ate what you ate.
Uh,
just,
uh,
we both had that giant Tomahawk.
Yup.
I had wine though.
Yeah.
Um,
I'm curious about this.
I'm very curious and I think I might try it,
but I eat a lot of vegetables,
but I don't have any problems like health.
Hey Man.
Like I'm not a disclaimer.
Number two,
I am not recommending this to anyone.
However,
I have had,
however,
I have had many,
many people come up to me on the tour and say,
look,
I've been following your daughter's blog and I've lost like a hundred pounds.
I think what?
You lost a hundred pounds.
See,
I lost a hundred pounds in six months.
I talked to a woman yesterday.
She lost 15 pounds in one month.
She was 70.
It's like this is,
here's a question.
Why is everyone fat and stupid?
That's a question,
man.
Because it's new.
Is it?
Something's wrong.
Yes it is.
It's new and it's not sedentary lifestyle that that hypothesis doesn't seem to
hold water.
There's something wrong with the way we're eating.
And the,
what's wrong is that we're eating way too many carbohydrates,
I think,
but no x eight shift.
The elimination of most carbohydrates has made a big shift in my life.
And I do cheat occasionally with bread and occasionally with Pasta I will,
I will go off with ice cream and things along those lines.
But most of the time I'm just eating meat,
vegetables most of the time.
And then I'll have a cheat day,
like,
you know,
once a week or something like that.
Especially if I go to dinner,
I'll have a little pasta and it doesn't seem to mess me up too bad,
but I do feel shitty after I do it.
It's like for simple mouth pleasure,
I'm allowing myself to feel tired afterwards.
Yeah,
that's a big one,
man.
Yeah,
but like I,
yeah,
like,
well really I can go on about six hours to sleep now and it's so interesting
too.
Like I can't believe I can wake up in the morning.
I've,
that's never happened to me in my whole life.
And when I was a kid,
1312 I'd a bitch of a time waking up in the morning.
It was just brutal.
I just thought that's how it was.
This is what I mean.
Again,
I'm not a nutritionist either.
But what's fascinating to me is I haven't heard any negative stories about
people doing this.
Well,
I have a negative story.
Okay.
One of the things that both mckayla and I noticed was that when we restricted
our diet and then ate something,
we weren't supposed to,
the reaction to eating what we weren't supposed to was absolutely catastrophic.
Would it show,
what did you switch to or what'd you eat rather?
Um,
well the worst response I think we're allergic to or allergic,
whatever the hell this is.
Having an inflammation inflammatory response to something called sulfites and we
had some apple cider that had sulfites in it and that was really not good.
Like I was done for a month.
That was the first time I talked to Sam Harris.
You were done for a month.
Oh yeah.
It took me out for a month.
It was awful.
Really?
So,
and what,
so this is right before whole
truth conversation with Sam Harris had got stuck in the mud during,
I think the day I talked to Sam was like the worst day of my life.
Not because of talking to Sam,
but it was just physical.
Oh Jesus,
I was so dead,
but I didn't want to not do it because cider,
like what was his all fights in it?
What was it doing to you?
Oh,
it,
it produced an overwhelming sense of impending doom and I seriously mean
overwhelming,
like there's no way I could have lived like that if that would have lasted for,
see,
mckayla knew by that point that it would probably only last a month and I was
like a month for month fucking cider or I didn't sleep that that month.
I didn't sleep for 25 days.
I didn't sleep at all.
I didn't sleep at all for 25 days.
How is that possible?
[inaudible] I'll tell you how it's possible.
You lay in bed frozen in something approximating terror for eight hours and then
you get up.
Oh my God.
Oh yeah.
And not some fucking cider from sites.
What we thought.
Yeah.
I mean,
look again,
I don't know what the hell I'm talking about.
Okay.
This is all a mystery to me.
The fact that my daughter was so sick.
See the one thing that I did know,
because I scoured the literature on arthritis when she was a kid,
the scientific literature and cause we are interested in the dietary connection
and the only thing I could find that was reliable was that if people with
arthritis fasted,
their symptoms reliably went away.
And that's actually well documented finding.
But then if they started to eat again and there were symptoms came back and I
thought,
well what the hell does it not matter what they eat?
They can't be reactive to everything.
It's like no,
but they can be reactive to all,
most everything.
And the difference between everything in almost everything.
That's a big difference.
And so mckayla seems to be,
maybe me too.
And Tammy's on the same diet because she has autoimmune problems on her side of
the family.
And so mckayla seemed to inherit all of them.
Your skin looks better.
Oh Jesus.
Joe,
I'm way better here.
Yeah,
yeah,
you,
you look like more vibrant.
It's very strange.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
Well,
my point is that you're saying that there is a,
there is problems with his die,
but that doesn't seem to be a problem with the dyed seems a problem with
deviating from the Diet that your body becomes accustomed.
Well,
one of the hypothesis that we've been pursuing,
and there's some justification for this in the scientific literature,
is that the reason that you lay on layers of fat because the fat acts as a
buffer between you and the toxic things that you're eating.
Because fat is actually an organ.
It has functions other than merely the storage of,
of,
of calories.
And maybe when you strip out that protective layer,
then you're more sensitive to what you shouldn't be eating.
This is all speculative hypothesis,
right?
Or maybe you sensitize yourself by removing it from your constant diet.
I don't bloody well,
well,
no.
Well,
I would think it would be much more likely that because you think about people
who are alcoholics,
they develop a tolerance to alcohol.
You get off of that and then you have a drink and your tolerances are shot and
then you immediately have a,
an adverse reaction to the alcohol.
Same thing with marijuana.
When people do it all the time,
you,
your body becomes tolerant.
Well,
I think,
I think that the layering of fat on might be part of the tolerance mechanism.
So it's not merely a matter of caloric intake,
it's a matter of of toxic caloric intake,
buffered by whatever it is that fat is doing as a Neuroendocrin Oregon.
But again,
like I said,
I said,
I'm out of my depth here,
but you know,
the whole,
everyone's out of their depth that God damn food pyramid was made by the
Department of Agriculture,
not the Department of Health.
It wasn't predicated on any scientific studies whatsoever.
We shouldn't,
we shouldn't be eating massive quantities of corn syrup.
We eat,
we eat way too many carbohydrates.
W MCKAYLA posted a paper the other day,
a doctor,
a successfully treated type one diabetes with a carnivore diet type one,
not type two.
So that's bloody impressive.
Yeah,
it's,
it's very curious to me because what you're talking about,
the one adverse reaction,
which is when you deviated from the Diet.
Yeah,
but I'm talking about is when I read people's accounts of trying this diet,
it's almost universally positive.
But again,
well,
it's probably anecdote,
right?
I mean,
I'm not sure,
and it's the same with all these stories that I'm collecting as I'm touring and
you know,
people,
lots of people have come up to me and said,
look,
I lost 45 pounds in the last three months I think.
I think Wa it's shocking to me.
I think,
well,
do what you make of that and say,
I can't believe it.
Well,
who can all,
I couldn't believe it.
50 pounds.
It's like,
first of all,
I didn't know I had 50 pounds to lose.
You know,
I thought it was maybe 20 pounds heavier than I should have been.
Should have been [inaudible] 85 something like that.
I guess that's 25 to 30 pounds.
That was the maximum thought.
No,
no.
I lost,
I met one 62 and I was at two 12 so what's that?
50 50 balance has a lot of weight.
Jesus,
I threw,
I draw all my clothes away.
I can't believe it.
When I saw you last night,
I was like,
you're so slim.
Like you're,
your stomach is completely flat and,
and this is not a lean mean fighting machine man.
And you're not a,
a an exercise fanatic.
It's not like you're starving yourself.
It's not like you're going,
I'm not having fun.
That's another thing I should say to people.
If you want to try a diet like this,
you eat enough meat and fat so you are not hungry.
Okay.
You can't get hungry.
You're not eating enough.
If you're hungry,
if you're hungry,
you're going to cheat and it's going to drive you stark raving mad.
The other thing that was really cool is like,
I really liked sweets.
Like I've kind of lived on peanut butter sandwiches and chocolate milk.
Not,
not really,
but that was my goal to food,
you know,
both of which were terrible for me.
Um,
but,
um,
after I stopped eating carbohydrates for a month,
the carbohydrate cravings went away.
You know,
last night when we were out for dinner,
somebody ordered bread pudding and I bloody love bread pudding with Carolyn and,
and ice cream.
And so it was sitting there and I could smell it and I,
you know,
I thought I could go all fantastic Mr. Fox on that bread pudding and just tear
it down in about 15 seconds.
But it wasn't,
it wasn't as intense as a craving for a cigarette.
If you're an ex ex smoker,
it was like pod be really nice to eat that.
But like my appetite declined by about 75% and that's been permanent.
That's been so there's a perverse thing for you.
I eat way less and now I'm not as hungry.
Okay.
Well how does that make sense?
Well you're not eating way less.
You eating way less thing.
Cause you had a 30 ounce steak last night.
Yes.
I'm,
I'm doing my best not to be hungry,
although it didn't look like it was 30 no,
no,
no.
This is a small 30 out of state.
Well I think it starts out 30 ounces before they cook.
It loses a considerable,
right.
Very Fatty.
Right.
But that's the other thing to you.
You must have to get a lot of fat.
Yeah.
Well I eat fatty cuts of steak and mckayla is buying fat directly from the
butcher store and we cook that up,
cut it into small pieces and fried up until it's crispy.
Wow.
It's actually quite delicious.
It's not bread pudding with ice cream,
but it's a funny,
you mean Daniel?
It's so ridiculous.
I want your blood profile.
I want to find out what's going on with you because one of the big myths,
misconceptions when it comes to cholesterol and saturated fat and food is that
if you eat dietary cholesterol,
that it affects your blood cholesterol levels.
It's not.
It's super common misconception.
Well,
those,
so the thing about clinical studies with diet are virtually impossible to
conduct because you just can't,
you can't conduct a proper randomly distributed controlled experiment.
It's too hard.
So a lot of what we're trying to do is pull out information from correlations,
right?
He can't do it,
which is one of the real problems with correlating meet with cancer and
diabetes.
And all these different diseases is because people are eating a bunch of shit
with that.
Oh yeah.
And they have different lifestyle profile.
There's just endless numbers of confounding variables and you only need one
confounding variable that's,
that's relevant to screw up the study.
Right?
You can't get that information with correlational studies.
We tried because it's impossible to do the studies,
but how many people were incredulous?
We win.
How many people when they're hearing about this?
Oh everybody,
everybody,
well you are not,
but you know,
you're interested in this sort of thing.
But they should be incredulous.
Like when people make absurd claims,
it's like,
oh,
well I had 50 health problems and I stopped eating everything but meat.
And they went away.
It's like,
oh sure.
yeah,
well it wasn't you dying.
So,
and I see the results and I know it's an anecdote.
I bloody will understand that.
And I'm highly skeptical about all of this,
but I'm telling you.
So that's why I'm telling you what happened to me and what happened to my
daughter.
And also what happened to my wife,
because she's,
Tammy was always in good shape and she's exercised a lot and she reduced to the,
to the,
uh,
pure carnivore died about a month ago.
She lost like 12 pounds and she was already slim.
She's back to the same way she was when she was 21.
She's,
she's like 58,
you know,
and she doesn't look 58.
I can tell you that.
So it's really fascinating.
It's really fascinating because I just,
I
as a person who studied diet for many years,
I would assume that you need fido nutrients,
I would assume.
Do you need vi vitamin supplement?
Like vitamin C for example?
It turns out if you don't eat carbohydrates,
you don't need vitamin C.
Huh?
Who would have guessed that was at work?
I don't,
I don't remember mckayla outline to paper.
For me,
vitamin C is necessary for carbohydrate metabolism,
but if you don't,
if again,
remember everyone listening,
I am not an expert in this field.
Right.
So,
um,
but,
but
I want you to get your blood test it because I think,
yeah,
if be pretty funny.
If it was in good shape it would be,
and I'd like to find out what your nutrient levels are and where they're coming
from.
I mean,
what,
how much nutrients are you getting?
Getting a little cramping in my toes from time to time.
So I'm not sure about potassium or magnesium.
That's a possibility.
Supplement.
It's very easy,
which is why I'm concerned about,
and also minerals,
you know,
in certain minerals you're getting from vegetables that you're probably not
getting.
Yup.
Well this is all like,
look,
it seems that hard
supplement that stuff though.
Colloidal minerals,
you know,
there's some mineral pills you can take plenty of.
Well there are people,
there are people who basically lived on meat.
Do you know the,
anyway,
did the Messai basically dead and there there's some supplementation,
but not a lot.
Yeah.
And apparently if you do a carnivore diet,
you're supposed to eat more organ meat.
And I do some of that,
but not a lot.
But I can tell you like I'm right,
I'm in.
Well look,
I wouldn't be doing this if it wasn't producing positive results.
It's like,
it's not like it's fun.
I mean for awhile.
Well it makes you a social pariah.
It's like let's invite the Peterson's over.
Oh yeah,
they don't eat anything.
Oh,
we have other friends that's like,
well that's how it works.
It's not malevolence right.
It's just if you're a pain,
no one invites you out.
So I'm a social pain in an ideological pain and now I'm a nutritional paints.
Like I know friends.
How difficult is it when you're trying to get breakfast?
Like what do you do when you oil?
Lots of times when we were traveling,
we cook,
so we usually stay in places where you can cook,
but most places you can get a steak and so that's mostly what we do.
I've been traveling in a motor home and so we've been cooking in the motor home
and so I carry beef jerky with me,
which we make.
Yup.
It's crazy.
You make your own beef Jerky dehydrator and you just basically put salt on it
and thrown the dehydrator.
So that works pretty well.
You anticipate continuing this?
Well,
I ever cod forever is a long time.
I'd like to be able to eat more things,
but I'm going to experiment with that very,
very,
very cautiously.
I'm going to add mushrooms next because maybe I could eat them.
Well,
this is why I'm asking.
There's
positive benefits that a lot of people achieve.
Um,
and and experience when they switched to a Vegan Diet.
Right?
What things it is,
is you get off of the standard American diet with lots of refined sugars and a
lot of preservatives in bullshit and then you find positive benefits.
Chris Kresser has gone into depth about this,
but then over time to nutritional deficiencies
in that start to wear on your health.
Yeah,
and I'm wondering whether or not you're going to experience,
it's certainly possible while it certainly,
eventually this diet will kill me.
No life will,
well,
you're right.
Biology will,
unless science intervenes.
Might be that for some people have of a Vegan diet is,
or Vegan Diet.
Is it preferable to a standard American Diet?
So for sure,
to a standard American diet,
but also there's so much biological variability.
Yeah.
You know,
the things that bothers some people don't bother other people at all.
And that's,
that's something that we got to take into consideration.
Yeah.
Well that's why I didn't want to universalize from my experience,
you know,
but,
but this is what's happened to me and this is what's happened to my wife and my
daughter.
So,
and all of it's been,
well with mckayla lights,
it's miraculous.
I cannot believe it.
The last time I saw it made me cry.
I've never seen her look like that.
She looks so good.
She's so healthy and over.
Other joints are not experiencing any problems.
And she's taking no immunomodulators at all.
No medication,
none.
And she was on him for Jesus.
Yes.
More medication than you can shake a stick at methotrexate,
which is basically a,
they use it to treat cancer.
It's,
uh,
it's,
what,
what is,
what's the cancer treating drugs called?
Whatever.
I don't remember at the moment she was on Enbrel,
which really,
really helped,
but,
but later open to bacterial infection.
So she always had pneumonia in the fall.
Um,
but enbril really helped.
and then heavy doses of antidepressants and Ritalin and Jesus.
It was,
how long has she been on this carnivore diet?
Oh God,
she's only been eating meat.
It's gotta be least six to eight months now.
Wow.
And does she get blood work done?
Uh,
Yep.
And her blood work.
I won't comment on that.
I don't know the details of her blood work.
Um,
so I don't know if I answered that.
It's fascinating.
I'm curious.
I'm,
I'm considering trying it for awhile.
The problem is I,
I eat so much game meat and there's not a lot of fat.
Get some fat.
That's the trick there.
Tried for a month,
see what happens.
You,
what the hell?
A month,
you know,
just a month.
Yeah.
Now months.
Not Hard.
Yeah.
Interesting.